[Music]
once there was a tree and she loved a
little boy every day the boy would come
and say gosh I love you tree let's be
together forever why that would be
lovely child and I will always be here
for you the boy loved the tree and the
tree was happy but time went by and the
tree got older and the tree was often
alone then one day the boy came to the
tree and the tree said boy
[Music]
wait
go see The Lorax find out how you too
can save the trees
[Music]
[Applause]
no invite of the giant furry peanut
right up your nose
whoo you wouldn't hit a woman I am The
Critic I speak for the Zeus observing
how long will this all shake out looks
The Lorax
a book that's read by a ton has been
ripped into shreds and can't be undone
the timelessly written book of all ages
comes to the dumb of the focus-group
cases well I'm standing up for the small
hairy orange I'm going on up there and
you know I'm done running to the Lorax
being a huge hit yes
now let's see if we can make a
live-action version of good night moon
starring Madea oh great another pep talk
from the Seuss Nazi or as I like to call
them Susie's you think you can get away
with dumbing down dr. Seuss like you
deal with I can't have the Grinch follow
poison did I kill you too
we're like mononucleosis we never fully
go away and we often put you to sleep
don't you see the harm you're doing to
the wonderful world dr. Seuss created
the box office disagrees indeed the
people love it but that's what's making
it worse
do I really have to show you the obvious
problems you're causing no but I get the
feeling you're going to anyway this is
the Lorax
we open and feed villas the credits roll
Oh tell me completely have a plastic and
we're no trees exist at all
I like to thank this film for making me
realize how sick I am of over-the-top
upbeat musical intros sorry opening to
the Muppets movie I have to hate you now
so we see a gap kids commercial meet up
with an Abercrombie & Fitch commercial
voiced by time with acting giant Zac
Efron and Taylor Swift oh hi Ted oh hey
Audrey
i Wow that is nothing I say expected to
come out of that kid you know because a
12 year old boy should always be voiced
by a 26 year old man right all right
cool hey I gotta run I gotta go do a
thing so I'll see you guys I'm pretty
sure that's how they do in the Iron
Giant isn't it - come on right no you
wait eh it turns out this girl is an
artist who paints pictures of trees and
dreams one day being able to see a real
one if a guy somehow got you one well
I'd probably marry him on the spot I bet
that sounds crazy
does that sound crazy well that depends
do you mean it literally or do you have
a good sense of humor or nothing else is
gonna be revealed about you in this
movie is it here just a bland piece of
who asked to get his truffle of growing
so he can set out on this movie's
hypocritical quest aren't you in people
said that the touch of their Tufts was
softer than anything well any other
cliche characters horse I like to call
the cliche occurs you'd like to get out
early in the movie the fracking granny
okay okay
any others disco
the embarrassing parent painful very
painful any others the more smog in the
sky the more people will buy oh of
course the corporate bad guy who owns
the town with no redeeming elements
whatsoever you could call him the
missing Captain Planet villain shippi
why he's so evil he wants to actually
sell fresh air to people because their
pollution is already destroying the air
that they have um
Spaceballs did it I make a living
selling fresh air to people trees oh
they make it for free consider it kind
of a threat to my business okay first of
all if you're gonna steal end of modes
design sheet pick a voice that matches
those vocals match about as well as oh
hey Audrey that second isn't the idea of
the Lorax that there is no real bad guy
it's just a cautionary tale of when
someone anyone takes too much without
seeing it unless someone like you cares
a whole awful lot nothing is going to
get better it's not but you don't
understand we don't want people to feel
bad about themselves yes people are less
likely to buy things when they feel bad
it's easier to show a clear right and
wrong message so that no kids are
confused but maybe they should be
confused help maybe what you're doing is
confusing them in a different way look
when you make your characters less human
you suck out the humanity meaning people
are less likely to see what they can
become Danny
you know he's even your good man the
glam not as evil as that guy yeah just
like a delicate seed can grow a great
oak so can a faulty message grow a big
problem
yes but clearly we show it in a
satirical sense so that makes it all
right in what way I was laughing at the
bad things you do make it any less bad
well the chart says yet so many trump
watches the boy leave the town to find a
tree leading him of course to the home
of the once-ler
well there went the surprise of the
powerful line that closed out the
original oh it I'm just gonna
assume nothing in this film it's gonna
move me at all
it's really the best way to watch it are
you why are you doing here my god we
finally found Bill Watterson oh you want
to know about trees about what happened
to them why they're all gone so the once
a lair of course tells the story about
what happened to all the trees naturally
keeping his face hidden throughout the
story so like I said before he can
represent how this can happen to anyone
anyone watching right now you
you you you you you
you you you you
you you maybe I'm over-exaggerating
after all it is an hour and a half long
movie you now wanna have is a long time
to go without seeing your kinda main
character I mean it's an adaptation
I got it there's gonna have to be
changes from an adaptation fair enough
at the very least they're making him
timeless somebody that everyone can look
back on years later and not laugh at for
being so incredibly dated on the cheap
I don't care for that this one slur is a
super young electric guitar playing I
clothes wearing fedora hats Odin both
cultural referencing Zac breath
completely dated product of the times
gonna blow some minds yeah see hey yeah
no I know what's his problem
I'm just saying weirdo bull-fucking-shit
yes and the one slings seem to love him
the what the one slings apparently our
character was so hip with the ladies
that they decided to form an online
community around him engage oh my god
this was a thing yes and we even have
one online right now
she calls herself hyper fangirl oh my
god guys I just love all the emo haircut
you're giving to the dr. Seuss
characters you're giving them a style
that'll last forever like the Jonas
Brothers why do you love this once-ler
he's every other quirky alternative
product mix into a Michael Cera action
figure Fisher called him a hipster who
he is clearly not a hipster hipsters act
like they don't care how they look and
then they take seven hours to put their
outfits together he clearly only took
six you can't just like someone because
he's really nerdy into retro media wears
a bunch of hat professional half grungy
Club
[Music]
what are you doing this evening not you
dumper you know you really are a bit of
a hipster shut up
so the once-ler I'm shot comes across a
landfill with trees and painfully
obvious minion backwash as he starts to
chop them all down for his new business
little did I know by dropping down that
tree I had just summoned a mystical
creature as old as time itself that
danny davito cameo of course the Lorax
is in one of the trees as all the
characters circle around the chopped
down life to mourn its loss
[Music]
well that's actually a very touching
moment that fits the spirit of the book
it's new it's different but it keeps to
the message love then even kind of
subtlety of what soos was going for how
do they it up well clearly we can
make the message much more powerful by
adding in Mission Impossible Limoges a
[Music]
dozen more of those minion moments and
the nonviolent pacifist Lorax of the
original now tried to drown our hero in
the hope that that'll lead him away
oh and don't forget a few more lame-ass
pop cultural references why aren't you
like other kids breakdancing and playing
Donkey Kong so Donkey Kong is now
officially part of the dr. Sue's cannon
I don't know about that I know it's so
retro hold me so the Wilford Brimley
Oompa Loompa feels bad about almost
drowning the once-ler
so he makes it up to him by tearing the
out of his new home it was cold
outside we just fell asleep okay I put
my lips on the boy ooh what's for
breakfast
breakfast is overrated why do you have
one of these you don't even have a
Mustang yes teaching lessons about
staying out of others environments as
mean what's stronger by invading your
environment I got work to do
yep I gotta go into town and sell my
meat so the once-ler makes a deal with
the Lorax that he won't cut down any
more trees and that the one he got is
enough to sell his product called a
thneed
hey cool hat that thing makes me like
you more ah how advertisers thought
marketing for the Lord's would work and
sadly didn't work
[Music]
and there with my enjoyment for the
upbeat lego movie song realize it would
be over yo I should point out that it
does sometimes cut back to our main lead
still suffering from bland millennial
itis but they're so rushed and so
generic that you forget about them just
as soon as you watch them I think the
most that happens is the man paints over
flower girls artwork why what's that
even supposed to accomplish is that
really gonna make such a big difference
it's kind of like saying oh you want to
see Elsa and Jack Frost
together well what have we just put add
red eggs over your fan art now you'll
never want to see them again as long as
you live will you did you damage my fan
art I still love you
[Applause]
[Music]
so the ones whose family comes out to
live with them and once again it's not
the once-ler himself who's consumed by
productivity that would make him
interesting identifiable and complex no
it's just as evil family that aids him
on so I guess as long as you don't have
one of those this could never happen to
you we could always start chopping down
the trees but no buts one see you're
running a business now you have to do
what's best for the company and your
mama even his progression seems hastily
rushed the original was good at showing
the ones led to bate himself but then
always find an excuse to keep going
bigger and even the story never claimed
that going to another extreme was the
answer
warning a one I should shut down my
factory why are a hundred thousand
workers I see your point but I wouldn't
know the answer it was trying to find
that middle row that wasn't victimless
but was the best compromise we could
come up with here one song and oh
overnight this
instead of slowly but surely over the
course of the film we see the
progression of all these choices and the
effect that it's having it's just one
song
Anakin Skywalker's transition was more
complex and there's your allegory for
the movie right there just take a
picture with the Lorax on your product
then boom it suddenly Lorax approved
ironic this song it's against everything
corporate when that's exactly what the
Laurens marketing was doing enjoy your
air polluting car The Lorax says it's
okay on top of that have you noticed
that out of the five songs in this movie
only one is Pro trees and it's only
played at the end and yes I know they're
being ironic and praising over
productivity but by god four upbeat
modern style pop songs about it and only
one one song that actually says
give a damn about the trees
don't you see even a little bit of a
problem with that it says the people
with the bar name they're not even
timeless songs they don't sound like the
top ten from Radio Disney well we're
just trying to reach the most popular
demographic you can respect that
trying to get your message out to as
many people as possible by toaster
pandering
yeah but the popular way isn't always
the lasting way look again
fad is just one letter away from fate
and that's exactly what they do they
fade away that's why it's fair to focus
on being good rather than being popular
if you can be both great but if you have
to choose one over the other always pick
good over popular because once the
people grow out of it and move on to the
next popular thing there's nothing of
substance to bring them back
and the timeless method you claim to
fight so hard for becomes just another
passing trend to forget about it's okay
the internet speeds up everything yes
it'll be popularly read true in five
minutes and synchronize so as I'm sure
you guessed the once-ler finally chops
down the last tree and his business as
well as the forest is completely gone
The Lorax lifts his ass into heaven
leaving evil make obvious to be inspired
to be the next big tyrant wonder what
the next million-dollar invention is
gonna be I wonder
and of course you know how the rest of
the story goes the once-ler gives the
boy the last seed and is left up to him
as well as the children watching to make
the choice on whether or not they'll
grow a cleaner and better world leaving
on a powerfully quiet emotionally fueled
and subtly ambiguous final note any dr.
Seuss movie doing anything clever of
course they don't do that no this one
has car chases yeah cuz if there's
anything that people are complaining
we're missing from dr. Seuss if it was
more car chases how also we get
the big bad corporation is trying to
take control of the people tomorrow oh
my god they're making hail Hydra sound
like a weather-resistant German car
throw in a radical snowboarding granny a
tubular scooter that's probably
polluting the more times he rides around
on it seriously you're just talking do
you have to ride around in circles like
that
and we clearly see the town not over the
progression of time and patience but
rather instantly join the boys
sighs go out to plant a million trees
and sing another pop song about it
Oh God people were said are icing it
before it even came out how popular is
this song we even see the Lorax come
back yup he comes back removing all the
weight of ambiguity and sense of urgency
and instead gets the kids their happy
little ending you done good being pull
you're done good ah isn't that just
precious say while you're at it why
don't you just clarify that Bambi's mom
never died yeah that was a bit of a
downer but what just clarify that she
came back and they all lived happily
ever after
come to think of it why don't you just
reveal whether or not the top falls over
in Inception oh won't you just tell us
what Bill Murray said to Scarlett
Johansson or give away what was in the
briefcase in Pulp Fiction because that's
what life is made up of right answers
easy non thought-provoking answers and
we need to prepare kids for just a
easy life is going to be yeah
sure they made us think but look at it
this way
they made us but thinking gives children
unclear answers well maybe that's the
idea goddamnit but maybe the message
will last longer because people keep
coming back to think about no no no as
our data has shown this has gone retro
right about now surely all the people
have written bucks my god that was the
last Lorax movie fan there's nothing
left to exploit yeah that's because
you've given them nothing challenging
and does nothing valuable to keep coming
back to well it's not as bad as the
grantor The Cat in the Hat and the
animation style is colorful and lends
its way to Souza's well bear the
live-action The Lorax still sucks in
capturing the spirit of dr. Seuss
instead of being poetic it panders to
the mainstream instead of having it
speak to everyone it paints extremes
that alienates the truth of the story
and instead of being dark and subtle it
knocks you on the head with its message
ironically making it far less memorable
people aren't gonna be coming back
because you gave them nothing that shows
you respect them as thinking people you
simplified it made it easy so easy that
nobody finds it fun anymore
I don't care how many movies you make
how popular they are for the moment or
how often you keep missing the spirit of
these great stories because no matter
what you do people are always gonna keep
returning to the books of dr. Seuss not
only because they remember them but but
because they're worth remembering critic
that's exactly what I wanted to hear
what what black Willy Wonka that's right
it was me all along this wasn't on your
resume oh look a popular demographic you
can exploit oh wait come with me ready
this is my black wonkavator
Wow does it go every way possible yes
every button goes a different direction
and I press them all except this one
what direction does that go
[Music]
hey what those of the people who saw the
movie sure are but they're reading the
book I thought they were doing with the
Lorax well you see Critic that was part
of my ultimate plan it was yes you were
right about Seuss his books will last
forever but sometimes people take that
for granted so what better way to remind
them of Seuss is power than making films
that completely them up so the
Grinch The Cat in the Hat The Lorax they
were all perfectly terrible and dated
they needed to be popular so that
everyone would see them but they also
needed to be horrible so everyone would
go back to remember just how good the
original stories were true beauty never
fades you just need to be reminded of it
once in a while if we're discovering
this I get your money-making secrets as
well as a lifetime of happiness no you
get a button
[Music]
thank you but critic don't forget what
happened to the man who got everything
he always wanted what happened I killed
him and stole all of his possessions
[Music]
I'm just saying